[inaudible]
[inaudible] in a town where you're never quite sure if you were in Mexico,
the old west, uh,
down-home us city with classic Americana feel or just up another coldest in
southern California. Endless suburban sprawl.
The one thing that seems to unite everyone is a love of good Mexican food.
I'm not just talking about your standard Tacos,
burritos and chips and salsa in this town.
I'm looking for Morley. There are more days Galore.
You've heard of Guacamole, but there are Red Malays, Black Malays,
green moleys. There are Malays with namesakes,
like the famous multiple Villano from the town of Pueblo in Mexico.
These are often linked proudly to some place a region. Wahaca is the
[inaudible], the land of the seven moleys, but don't forget,
we're back up here in San Diego.
Our story starts a few blocks past this beautiful stretch of architecture at the
city's famous zoo with this guy. I bring him up for two reasons.
One. He's a subject of extreme interest to some members of my travel party
and to his historical territory includes much of Mexico where he was and even
still is an iconic figure for many traditional cultures,
cultures like the Aztecs.
And that's where I show you that we're on this tangent for a reason besides
showing you fuzzy animals, because like the Mayan,
the Zapotecs as take people's ground of chilies and other ingredients and cook
them together to form these beautiful sauces.
And they've done this for hundreds and hundreds of years.
Don't think that these groups are all just Pre-columbian peoples of ancient
Mexico either. The language of the ancient Aztecs was classical.
Now what? And today there are more than a million speakers of modern.
Now what that brings us to the real stuff, these savory,
spicy, complex sauces, that's what you're here for, right?
The Aztec word is moly.
The Spanish added some ingredients to the mix and added their language to the
mix too. But sometimes the mixing went both ways.
The Spanish borrowed the word Moly, pronounced it more lame,
and that's the way it sounded when these hardy Mexican sauces made their way to
the southwestern quadrant of these United States where a lot of people speak
English, at least in some towns and some days,
thanks to all this history,
you can scour San Diego for mo lays in English or more or less in Spanish.
But I don't know how much luck you'll have speaking now. Wattle around here.
[inaudible].